there's 8-year-olds watching porn on
mobile phone that is their sex
[Music]
education The Narrative is still too
much focused on what women can do as if
women can prevent men from raping
assaulting abusing no Liberals are in
many ways the enemy of
feminism hello I'm Julie bindle and this
is action men a series in which I have
interesting conversations with men that
actually get up off their backsides and
contribute to the work that feminists
are doing to prevent rape domestic
violence and challenge pornography and
the sex trade today I'm speaking with
Bon sukta who is a
campaigner and an activist against men's
violence and in particular the porn and
sex trade good to talk to you and yeah
would you tell me something about
yourself Who You Are what you do and how
you got to be sitting here today talking
to me um so yeah my name is BJ um I'm
one of the co-founders of male allies
challenging sexism um
and oh where to start I guess you know I
was born in the sort of like early ' 80s
in Germany um West Germany that is in
sort of like a well fairly workingclass
environment I guess and
um yeah we you know there was four of us
my brother my dad my mom but I think
it's sort of like quite Liber upbringing
mainly my mom my dad wasn't really
around you know he was I think the first
or like 8 10 years of my life he was
kind like drinking quite a lot just you
know doing stuff like that my mom was
looking after us so like that was the
upbringing was quite liberal my dad was
quite a lot more conservative if I'm
honest but you know that wasn't really
noticeable cuz he wasn't really there so
that was quite interesting um and you
know
when when I turned 13 we moved to the
Netherlands from Germany so that was
quite a change
so yeah and then I just sort of like did
all my secondary education my University
there and you know I mean I'd probably
say Holland is even more liberal than
Germany in a lot of ways on on the
surface that is anyway um but I really
noticed that when sort of like 2001 came
along with the attacks on the World
Trade Center that actually Holland isn't
that liberal it's very liberal If you're
sort of like you know you belong you're
white you're sort of like fa in middle
class and once you scrape the surface
off it's actually pretty pretty bad in
well something else happened in Holland
in 2001 which is that brothel
prostitution was
legalized yeah the infamous window
prostitution that sex tourists will yeah
come to visit and it's everywhere which
where were you in Holland um I was in a
place called ner which is on well sort
of like East Central I guess but you
know like we had I mean that's where I
went to university around that time but
you know there was wound of prostitution
there you could find it everywhere of
course and people think it's just in
Amsterdam and it's just in the old the
the center of Amsterdam but we know that
it's all over Holland and since
legalization it's really really ramped
up sex tourism and the numbers of pimps
and prostituted women and trafficked
women that must have had some effect on
you seeing that all around you is so
normalized yeah and is is just normal
you know like you'll be walking around
town in the middle of the night and
there's a road and there's just guy
looking into windows and you're like oh
what's going on there and then you kind
of just realized like okay but then it's
just also kind of normal because nobody
sort of goes like what are you doing you
know it's it's just like a really weird
like buying a burger yeah it's it's just
really random and you know like I mean
in Amsterdam there's obviously like the
more famous parts of Amsterdam where
that is but like there'll be also other
bits and you know in Belgium it's the
same in Brussels I know there are
certain areas
where men will go to but it just kind of
becomes part of the fabric and the thing
that I realized really so like thinking
about is you know I think from my point
of
view like any sort of movement against
that didn't really exist in Holland like
it was just all sort of you know freefor
all Liberation kind of um well I would I
would call it capitalism not Liberation
but it was just sort of like you know
this is fine these people choose to do
that and and it's just you you can't
really move that conversation around in
Holland it seems well now it's starting
to shift there is an Abolitionist
Movement made up of feminists and other
human rights campaigners because at one
stage it was only the the kind of very
Hardline Christians who took a very
moralistic line against the women um I
mean I'm sure that many of them were
well-meaning but they weren't
approaching it from a feminist point of
view but one thing
that really made sense to me when I was
researching Holland for my book on
prostitution was how tourists get their
information so you know when you talk to
anyone in the UK or wherever
they'll tell you that Holland well they
used to before the movement started to
dismantle This brilliant legalized model
they'd say something like oh well of
course in Holland it works really well
there's no trafficking there's no
underage girls there's no drug dealing
there's no
pimping well of course that's not true
so how do all of these people get that
impression well I'll tell you how tour
guides you know all of the tour guides
around all of the hotspots all of the
tourist hotspots not just Amsterdam just
do you know who trains them oh let me
guess the prostitute Collective that is
on in the red light district in
Amsterdam which
is staffed by lobbyists for the sex
trade and they make money from tourist
popping in and visiting them and getting
a tour of the red light district yeah
and so they then offered
to I suppose inform all of these tour
guides
as to how the red light district works
now had I been informing the T guys I
would have said there's been a massive
increase in trafficking there's been a
huge increase in pimping there's
violence towards the women sex tourism
is a blight on the entire country and I
would have given them a lot of facts and
figures that differ rather a lot from
what the prostitutes Collective G yeah
they they did well you know in inverted
Commerce to kind of like put a certain
spin on it that just kind of like
neglected all of the negative effect oh
totally and it became a truism but let's
go back to you and
your Youth and your University days
because what I want to try and get a
picture of is how and when you started
being involved in feminism because
you've got a background that is quite
interesting and not kind of usual um
yeah I guess it's not very
straightforward I think you know sort of
like partly growing up sort of like
quite you know with a quite liberal mom
I think one of the things is that she
didn't really bat an IID about most
things you know like she was quite easy
going with most stuff so like I was like
12 and I was watching certificate 15
films left right and Center know loads
of violence loads of sex loads of
everything she was quite happy with that
and also you know there wasn't many
conversations about things like violence
or sex and how that works um so you know
and I had an older brother which also
helped so you know it was quite easy to
kind of get into quite early on to get
into you know objectification of women
um um when I moved to the
Netherlands um they were really far
advanced in terms of Internet so I think
we got the internet when I was 15 or
16 and you know the internet being the
internet the first stuff that was on
there was just awful I mean there was
quite you know use things information
and stuff but there's also a lot of porn
on there and you know give a 15 16y old
and a like 19y old access to the
internet don't supervise it what they're
going to find I think my mom just also
didn't know she was just sort of like oh
if this internet there's information on
that kind of thing you know well
Liberals are in many ways the enemy of
feminism because they assume a Level
Playing Field and they also tend to
assume that pornography is merely a kind
of part of you
know leisure activities is acceptable
yeah without looking at the power
differentiations and how sex means
different things to women and and to men
who were kind of groomed by the porn
industry so what changed um so I met my
partner when I was about
206 and she was a feminist so um at at
one point she found out there was
watching for and she's like well that's
not I hope she whooped your ass if she
did deservedly so um and at the end of
the day like well either sort it out or
it's bye um and you loved her and I said
okay that's it no more so I got a few
books there was one that I got which was
um confronting your spouse's pornography
problem that I read and I got Bob
jenson's book getting off um I started
reading all around it we talked to Bob
for this yeah series and he's brilliant
you know I I love how he he makes it
really personal and you know I can't I
can't read that book even nowadays
without sort of like tearing up because
it's just so personal and it's just so
real and and I recognize a lot of it and
I think you know sort of like seeing it
from that perspective for the first time
I was just
like okay H you know and it's just sort
of like somebody just sort of like
turned the mirror that way and it's like
I mean I actually remember um one
time having to be told I was very young
I was still in my teens at that stage
when I got involved in
feminism I had to be reminded that there
were real women in the pornography I
don't mean because I hadn't noticed that
there were actual photographs of real
women but I think I'd said something
like yes and this is terrible and it's
almost like a roleplay of women being
raped and somebody said well those women
are
raped they are real women yeah and I had
not made that connection because it was
probably too painful to make that
connection because we knew we were
against pornography because it sent a
message to men that women were vessels
and orifices
and the like but the most painful thing
that I
learned was actually that this is not
these are not
images I mean they are yeah but they're
a crime
scene and more so now of course because
pornography has become so much more
sadistic here's another thing what about
the stereotypes about anti-sexist men
pro- feminist men what about the fact
that you are
often
derided I suppose there are two sides to
this one is that you're not real men or
you wouldn't be doing this and obviously
they're not going to be feminists saying
that to you but the other side is my
people saying ah you anti-sexist
men I don't know just I don't do it but
mistrusting you or thinking that you all
knit your own
sandals uh or you're all vegan kind of
you know Green activists I happen to be
vegan but there we go well um get out of
this studio that is a disgrace no no but
seriously I mean what about the
stereotypes and what about the fact that
obviously there is some truth in
stereotypes there is some truth in
stereotypes and I think both of the ones
that you mentioned probably play into
the same thing just from two different
sides and you know like you said the um
famous you know oh you're a feminist do
you just want to get laid then which we
you know I'd forgotten about that one it
was it was that was very prevalent when
back in the 80s and 90s it was never
trust an anti-sexist man because he's
just doing it to find a nice feminist
girlfriend yeah and and you know and and
and I've gotten that quite a few times I
mean there was even a tweet that went
out like a couple of months ago with
basically that sentiment like the day
after a conference and I was like okay
I'm sure there's easier ways to get laid
than hanging around with feminists but
it's it just kind of goes to show that
what you said like oh you you're not a
real man then you know that kind of
aspect of it and I think that's which
is's very sexist it's deeply demeaning
to women CU if you're going to bother
yourself to give a damn about us what
does it say about the way they see us
but the interesting thing with that is I
think that argument comes more from men
because they kind of sort
of I don't know I I don't know what it
is but it's it kind of ties into the
whole thing of like you know if you're a
man you shouldn't like really have any
feelings or like you know be soft or
care about other people so like you know
you either must be like gay or you're
just doing it to have sex like one one
of those so these people can't actually
imagine that you would have a vested
interest in stopping men's violence on
having better relationships with women
in supporting women in the biggest issue
facing us all of us no that just doesn't
make sense somehow no you know and it's
and I I just never really know what to
say you know just sort of like okay like
it it just sort of to me seems like
really 12y old thinking you know like
you can't where there's like not really
any kind of common sense to what you're
saying you can't you can't really answer
on that level but then the other side of
this is I suppose
that feminists obviously want to cut you
down to size we want to stop you feeling
like you're entitled to do certain
things we want to remove some of the
power and privilege that you afforded at
Birth and often we're really horrible
about you I mean I I think feminism is
the most optimistic movement on the
planet because we don't think you are
born bad we don't think you are born
programmed to hurt or abuse or demean
women but seriously we are pretty
hardcore nasty and I don't mean the
women who go around wanting to Plate men
all the time like oh thank you for
coming to the conference and isn't it
lovely to have a man speaker I mean
proper feminist like me um a tough on on
men does that ever feel surely I mean
you're a human being do you ever think
oh God give it a rest put a sock in it
um I don't think like give it a rest I
think the thing that pops into my
mind well I want to go back actually to
the other thing that you said so like I
think we the thing that I'm very aware
of also is that there have been a number
of pro feminist men who have then sort
of been found to you know um abuse women
and I'm very aware of the fact that a
lot of women in feminism have been
abused in one way or another or there
will no women who've been abused so the
is the wolfing sheep's clothing thing
yeah and at the end of the day if I
understand I think it's a
realistic um
concern who are these guys like what are
they doing I think it's a realistic
concern and it's I think it's a fair
fair concern so like you know if I mean
we had some women come to our conference
this year so like I'm always happy for
women to come check us out it does feel
a little little bit you know oo am I
going to get it right yeah it would let
me feel uncomfortable I mean I suppose
the only way that the only analogy I
have is the first time I went to South
Africa to do some research there and
obviously it was well post-apartheid
this was about five six years ago and
when I realized how I was being treated
just because I was white
it felt very very uncomfortable cuz on
the one hand it was so nice and on the
other hand it was oh I don't like this
it's a tricky one isn't it it is and
there there's like multiple things where
it's sort of like well and and this is
also the the tricky thing with doing
something like this and which probably
stops quite a lot of men because you
will hear men say sort of like oh but
you know we'll just wait for the
feminist to tell us what to do um and I
think part of that would be clean our
houses actually
walk our dogs yeah through the dishes
you know there's that thing
where it it feels quite alien as a man
talking about you know Pro feminist
activism organizing because it's kind of
like but and then you also kind of feel
like oh well I don't really know about
this apart from from my own point of
view so I don't know from it from a
women's point of view but I can listen
to women then kind like give it my spin
um so that just kind of like feels a
little bit awkward sometimes and also
I'm
I I'm good at organizing I'm not
necessarily the best at speaking but I
think you know when it comes to when it
comes to those things it's it's good to
kind of like push yourself and to learn
and the thing that I've noticed is
actually you know 99.9% of the feminists
I talked to are all really supportive
they will tell you if you got it wrong
which is great cuz again 99.9% of the
time it's fair and it I think it's it's
one of the things that I really
appreciate because I think
with you know you always wind up
slightly generalizing but I think one of
the problems with male culture is is
that we let each other off too
much so it's kind of like oh I won't say
anything he's he my mate or like I won
know so it's kind of like it's quite a
like it's a bit like a big Fraternity in
a way you know like some sort of male
protection racket unconscious though
yeah sometimes yeah so like like I often
find like push comes to shove like I
quite often feel like a guy won't tell
me like straight up like what whereas
like with feminists
the the experience I've made is when I
say something wrong they will tell me
and yes that is
uncomfortable but if if I'm okay with
that if I don't feel like I'm being
personally attacked and I just kind of
think like all right here has a learning
opportunity he has somebody who's giving
me like the blank truth from their point
of view and actually this is about
something that affects her more than
me and maybe that carries quite a lot
more weight because like I don't live
this I'm I'm just sort of like looking
at it from the outside then it's like oh
okay I hadn't considered that and then
if I can you know if I can sort of like
put the defense mechanism to the side
and just be like okay this is somebody
who's experiencing this firsthand rather
than just looking at it from the
outside but one thing thing that you do
know a lot
about is the way that boys are
socialized and how easy it is to get to
that stage where you have dehumanized
girls and women and where that makes it
that bit easier to um sexually assault
to physically attack or just to put down
and coercively
control and what we need men to do is to
tell other men that's unacceptable there
will be consequences do not do this I
mean somebody said to me how are you
ever going to end up how are you ever
going to end rape and I said well it's
easy men just have to stop rape they
just have to stop doing it and stop
other men from doing it but of course I
was being glib of course it's not easy
but what do you think needs to happen
for us to get to a stage where there are
more men than there currently are cuz
you are a very small group we are that
are actually speaking out again against
male
violence I mean I think there needs to
be quite a few things I think the
narrative is still too much focused on
what women can
do you know as if like women can prevent
men from raping assaulting abusing no
you know we need to stop the people
doing it you know it's it just doesn't
work and you know because that they've
been trying that for decades and it just
does shift if anything gets worse so
what's the point and I
think as a society cuz I think it is up
to all of us you know especially all of
us men it's not enough to sort of say
like oh you know like oh I haven't got
kids or like whatever this doesn't
concern me or whatever it might be but I
think as men we all need to contribute
to that and I think you know especially
partly also because we make the majority
of the decisions like not personally but
you know the ones in power are mainly
men so I think you know whether it comes
to you know sex education in schools
needs to be much more up
toate you know and and people just need
to get comfortable talking to kids about
it because at the end of the day you
know I mean there's 8-year-olds watching
porn on mobile phone that is their sex
education that is their sex education
and like when somebody says like can you
talk to your 13 year about sex that's
like I'm not sure about this it's old
isn't it when you think think about the
sexualized culture in which we live the
pornified culture in which we live and
the constant references to female body
parts and
to demeaning and degrading sex acts done
to girls and women and you can't
actually sit a classroom full of kids
down and say okay here's what consensual
sex is this is about sexual pleasure
this is about the right to say no this
is how a baby is made it's very
I'm sure that we can do that if we can
also normalize the sexual harassment of
girls through pornography and constant
dickpics and the like exactly and I
think you know there's obviously part of
that where also the government and the
law can do much more that's very clear
you know I mean as I said I started
watching online porn when I was probably
16 like how is
it prob we like almost 30 years later
how are like 8-year-old now watching
porn if anything they should have sorted
it by now but you
know weirdly enough I feel like the the
story that I've heard for this last 15
years it's like oh this is the first
generation of boys who've grown up on
porn I'm like no not true that was 25
years ago like get a grip like check
reality cuz it's
literally not true you know like yeah
maybe now they're seeing at age but you
know kids growing up in like the 2000s
they would have started seeing it from
when they're like 14 and and it's you
know 3 4 years is more than plenty
to you know twist your brain so what is
the future of the pro- feminist men's
movement or the anti-sexist men's
movement whatever you want to call it
how can you swell your ranks get more
involved do you have any plans for the
future for more Global Connections cuz I
know you have some yeah I think that's
that's part of I I really want to be
building connections not just in the UK
but also beyond that so hopefully um
we'll get a group of men together to
write about their experiences of porn
and like why they stopped watching it so
we're trying to hoping to do something
with that because that's really
important because I think just talking
about that might actually get some
people to think about it at the same
time I think also just finding men and
you know like events are always useful
for that cuz if if you meet somebody in
real life it's a different thing than if
you just chat to them online so you know
we're going to try and do more events
where we can get men together talk about
it and then just sort of like slowly
grow and it's it's about making those
connections and having people to fall
back on and also having other men to
talk
about you know things that you maybe in
your normal life can't talk to people
about and also bringing bringing fresh
ideas and one of the really great things
because our last conference was in
Glasgow is I saw a video online um I
don't know six months beforehand there
was this guy called Rudy who's being
interviewed and I said oh he looks good
so I just sent a message on Twitter and
then we met up and there was a whole
group of gay men from Scotland who were
sort of organizing um particularly
around you know gender identity and then
I said like oh well we've got a group of
like straight guys down here you know
like and then sort of like having ation
about you know what we're in it for and
then you know making those connections
and then just talking to each other and
just learning things and exchanging I
think that's that's one of the things
that will keep it moving forward the one
slide concern I do have with the way
things are now is that I feel like you
kind of talked a little bit about the
different camps of feminism I think one
encouraging thing is in my point of view
there's more men interested in radical
feminism that I've met even just the
last two years than they have been
before which is mainly down to um you
know infringements of freedom of speech
not being able to talk about biological
sex all that kind of stuff because I
think that's to some degree quite a lot
closer to the Bone for men it kind of
seems like it's got more of a direct
impact whereas some of
the men who come more from
a violence against women standpoint have
been around a little bit
longer
um you know I don't like the phrase but
they're not necessarily gender critical
you know um so there's a little bit of a
split there which is slightly
disconcerting so oh the movement must be
going from strength to strength if
you've already got
factions but you know what I mean where
big enough to have the split that's good
but you know what I mean so there's
there will be things where um a c a
certain you know just like within
feminism there will be a certain group
of men who will sort of think like oh
yeah violence against women is bad but
I've got a fairly strong point on like
all the gender identity stuff so like if
you're doing this then it's a no so and
the thing that I do love as well is that
you do get men and you know we had we
had it at the confence and people will
have different ideas about this you know
like people will have a different stance
on abortion you know they might not be
anti-abortion but they might think that
you can't abort a child after 8 weeks
somebody else might think 12 somebody
else might think 16 somebody else might
think you should do it all the time you
know
and some of these things are just there
you can't just be like well I'm only
going to talk to you if you think
exactly the same as me yeah I'd just
send him offer of aect toy any bloke
that thinks that abortion should be
restricted came down the clinic yeah
well I actually mean it no I know you do
well some anti-sexist men have done that
they've taken themselves to the clinic
and but you know I should run a clinic
actually no no I don't want to do that
well free vasectomy fanti sexist man
just give you vasectomies yeah but you
know it's it's it's one of those things
and I guess the problem being is if you
know if we all go down the no debate
route like nothing will change
and yeah I disagree with you on that
fine but if we agree on this then maybe
we can do something about that and then
we can just let that be a difference do
you know what I mean I do otherwise I'll
just be chopping my limbs off left right
and center and just have nothing to do
at the end of it same here sounds very
familiar I've really enjoyed this
conversation it's been fun and
informative and obviously we'll carry on
speaking and I'll see you at the
conference tomorrow you will see you
there thanks so much thank
[Applause]
[Music]
you